[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: Please switch
your phone to silent
and take your seat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
The program is beginning
please be seated.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[KEYBOARDING SOUNDS]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome to the stage, President
of Sales and Operations, Google
Greater China, Scott Beaumont.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BEAUMONT:
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
OK.
Time to--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: It's
great to see all of you--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: --lead the way--
SCOTT BEAUMONT: --who
have Google Play--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[END PLAYBACK]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: Very good.
Very good.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: --the
products and services--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SCOTT BEAUMONT: Come talk to us.
SCOTT BEAUMONT:
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Ben Galbraith.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN GALBRAITH: A
pleasure to be here.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH:
--all the Chinese--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: It's a
pleasure to be with you.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: I had the
opportunity to visit China
three times this year.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Thank you.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: My family
would spend their days
learning Mandarin.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: --for me to be
able to spend time with you.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: I'm also pleased
to announce this morning--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: First, we worked
together with the web community
to develop and promote something
that we called progressive web
apps--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: The
developers who have
PWAs are seeing great results.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Naomi Black [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Please welcome to the stage the
lead for Angular, Naomi Black.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NAOMI BLACK: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[SPEAKING CHINESE] Naomi.
[SPEAKING CHINESE] Angular.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
I'm sorry.
I'm missing some of my notes.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
NAOMI BLACK: [INAUDIBLE]
NAOMI BLACK: Among the
additions we have in Angular,
we now have Angular material.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
NAOMI BLACK: So if you're one
of the millions of Angular 1
developers, you can
migrate at your own pace.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
NAOMI BLACK: So that the server
render our components' view.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
NAOMI BLACK: So now, I'd like
to introduce my colleague
Ben to come back on stage.
Xiexie.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Thank you, Naomi.
BEN GALBRAITH: So as
excited as I am all
about all the new developments--
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: And
we look forward
to delivering many more
enhancements to Firebase
in the years to come.
INTERPRETER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Xiexie.
INTERPRETER: Xiexie.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
Thank you for joining us.
Breakout sessions
will begin shortly.
Please see your badge for
room locations and schedule.